if you allow it the Apple watch will
constantly pull you out of the real
world and suck you into your digital one
with constant chimes wrist vibrations
and pop-up alerts it can and it will
take over your life if you let it
that is after three weeks of wearing the
Apple watch I've learned how to tame it
turning it from an accessory of
distraction to a tool a real usefulness
here's how I did it the first thing I
did was use the Apple watch iPhone app
to limit notifications coming to my
wrist this is a must do if you want to
prevent it from becoming this an iPhone
handcuffed within the notification
settings in the iPhone app I turned off
the alerts for almost all third party
apps trivia crack notification should be
illegal in general and certainly on my
wrist with Apple's own apps I did a lot
of customization for instance the
calendar app only pings my wrist for
upcoming events now not new invitations
I'm also no longer buzzed to stand up
when I've been sitting for so long since
I was ignoring those anyway see I'm
standing in line for a hot dog
this may seem monotonous but do it it
will save you endless pestering later on
which brings me to my second step I set
up my watch to be a lot like a club
bouncer only allowing in VIP emails the
bad news here is that this only works
with Apple's Mail app still it was
really helpful since I get emailed day
in and day out about all sorts of things
I don't care about now only emails from
my editor and other important contacts
hit my wrist next I just flat-out killed
all the third party watch apps and
glances I'll never use I don't need all
those weather apps I have on my phone
and when am I going to need to check my
onedrive on my wrist I also switched off
the setting that automatically downloads
apps you have on your phone onto your
watch I also turned up the glances for
most apps including Apple Maps since
they aren't only distracting but very
slow to load the last thing I did was
find some wheel power to limit
distractions even further in those times
when you're with real people it isn't
always easy but turning on Apple's do
not disturb mode when sitting down with
a friend or a colleague is a must for me
I also embrace turning off the red
indicator on the watch face which tells
you if you have unseen notifications in
some cases it just became too addicted
and that's the interesting thing about
the Apple watch as technology becomes an
extension of our bodies it's on us as
well to limit its distractions
the Apple watch should bury us in the
digital world but help us in the real
one